[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host jared aka breaking boards buck
who is here to also
break down all of the spoilers
okay in this video we're gonna be doing
a deep dive into cobra kai's season 5
we're going to be going into not only
the story and the nightclub dancing
shenanigans but also the ending this
latest season solves some of the issues
that plagued the dojos in season 4 while
also leaving some big things to be
explored in the future seasons with us
predicting whether or not the head of
the cobra is truly karate chopped off or
will two emerge from one now if you
enjoyed this video then please smack
that like button like a silver bullet to
the chest and also don't forget to
subscribe to heavy spoilers because
we're the
chosen ones for the best puns in the
valley with that out of the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
kobrakai season 5.
[Music]
okay so season 5 opens on an almost
global gym advertisement showcasing how
cobra kai is the peak of any dojo in the
valley having the best equipment
experience sensei's state of the art
snack bar and opening more and more
locations in the valley every single day
this ties into the ending of season four
where terrible terry tells crust
decrease he is finally shedding him of
his weakness and showing the world what
kobrakai can finally be which results in
chris going to prison because he is
framed for the assault on stingray
getting him out of the picture to no
longer interfere with the expansion of
the cobra kai dynasty with this
mentality of teaming up with your past
that crease and terry had going for them
is also in full force on the side of
miyagido not only with johnny and
daniel's son but chosen who shows up the
end of season 4 has become a
well-established member as a sensei at
miyagidou combining his teachings with
the other teachings of miyagido and
eaglefang now even though this season is
latching on to the idea of the past and
riding the wrongs for example in terry's
realm it's his failure of kobrakai back
in the 80s when he was rocking the sick
ponytail and snorting that booger sugar
the theme of not dwelling on that past
any sort of grudge or what if moment you
have in your mind and instead living in
the now the future is what makes us and
we shouldn't be judged on the past
choices that we've made this central
theme is reflected almost entirely
through all of the characters in this
season in miguel's case it's forgiving
his father for not being there to raise
him even though his father does still
turn out to be quite a dick and it's
heavily hinted that his father is a drug
dealer i mean with a name like hector
salamanca uh i mean hector salazar a
wrong one still the wrong one there we
go is everyone named hector salah
something automatically a bad guy anyway
that story thread honestly didn't amount
to much at all but hey at least miguel
gets to meet up with the point break
surfers led by mortal kombat's kano
everyone loves me
whose ass gets kicked by johnny later on
so i guess not all was lost later on
miguel forgives both robbie and sam as
well their relationship on again off
again throughout this season finally
does end up in a good position when sam
finds the octopus necklace that miguel
had bought for her earlier on and you
know the octopus is essentially their
relationship love language mascot going
all the way back to their first date in
season one johnny dwells on the past
when he finds out that he and carmen are
going to have a child yes surprise
johnny's little dudes kicked their way
all the way through carmen's uterine
wall yeah wow i probably could have said
that a lot differently huh but he does
want to be there for their new child
after realizing that he was never really
there for robbie and doesn't want this
to happen again showing the initiative
to be the best boyfriend he can be
cooking cleaning and baby proofing his
whole place for the upcoming child
together this added initiative is picked
up immediately by carmen not only in
real life but her dreams seem to be
influenced heavily by this new and
improved johnny in some hilarious top
gun reenactments johnny turns up the
heat in some aviator volleyball action
some motorbike scenes reminiscent of
maverick and charlie along with the
silhouetted love making scenes it's a
clever reference because both johnny and
carmen referenced the movie earlier in
the series reeling back to the central
theme johnny also mentions that for
years he's been thinking about what
would have happened if he would have
blocked that infamous kick from daniel
back in the all valley tournament how
much better could his life have been but
now almost takes a step back from all of
those notions and thoughts that have
been going around his mind and is now
almost content and happy with the
journey that has led him to where he's
at with carmen and his new friends and
this new baby that's on the way even
chosen who i thought would be way more
of a side character gets his time to not
only flesh out some of his teachings and
whoop some ass but there is some solid
character development from him and the
regrets that he has from the karate kid
part two he mentions that after those
events of that movie he was almost
labeled this coward of his village too
like johnny regretting the actions of
his past and that he kind of is now on
this redemption arc in a sense but also
how he still after all of these years
still has a longing for kumiko who was
featured in karate kid part 2. it's him
looking back and rethinking it's not too
late to show this person that i have
changed which is amazing growth from his
character in essentially you know the
karate kid part 2. because attempted
murder
isn't always the strongest pickup line
folks i'm curious if the two of them
will somehow wind up together in season
six because chosen was dropping some
saucy drunk voicemails for kumiko now
one of the biggest new additions to this
season was the introduction of the sake
take world karate tournament though
little information was given it's
supposed to be the most prestigious
karate tournament in literally all of
the world like all valley times like a
bajillion this can help expand the cobra
kai world and lore much further than
just the valley like i said it's quite a
tease don't get me wrong but both teams
winning invites to this world tournament
it allows for some characters from the
previous seasons and movies to make a
return
julie pierce
along with even more intense rivalries
and karate techniques it was fun to
watch the sekai taekai committee
spectate each of the dojo's trainings
because the contrast between these two
has heavy rocky 4 vibes running through
them while the kobra kai gym has state
of the art technology miyagi doe is
doing things way more like old school
kind of bare bones like the contrast
between rocky and drago do in that movie
johnny even references it a couple times
when talking with the committee about
running up some snow-covered peaks with
the committee head also agreeing that he
loves rocky iv johnny later on
references the ending speech about how
everyone can change both referencing the
movie and also tying in with the theme
of the past is the past and the future
is what really matters if i could change
and you can change
everybody can change
if i can change
the courses
and you can change
it
everybody should change
he gets it i do now one of the biggest
reveals in this season is that terry had
paid off the officials at the all valley
championship in season four biggest
shocker yet right meaning that tori's
trophy and win were essentially
illegitimate tori lets miyagido know of
this wrongdoing and it's essentially
their mission to recover any sort of
footage or proof to chop off the snake's
head once and for all there is a bit of
almost like a two-part plan here that's
going on where miyagido and kai students
all descend upon the cobra kai dojo
partaking in a huge karate orgy fists
and kicks everywhere while this karate
craze is happening across town johnny
chosen and mike barnes yes the same mike
barnes that was the fighter of terry
silver in the karate kid part 3 but
don't worry we'll we'll get to him later
just just hold on now silver's goon
squad of hand-picked senseis that
actually includes cameos from ufc
fighters steven
thompson and tyrone woodley so uh yeah
the the more you know i guess square off
against them but the three ninjas kick
back
this leads to chosen being struck down
by silver's katana and left for dead in
a pool of his own blood
just kidding he he survives however
silver is finally canceled because the
security cam footage of the tournament
bribes are finally uploaded to youtube
resulting in most of the cobra kai
students finally turning on the dojo you
know there's bad publicity for the cobra
kai name and terry silver is finally
having his crimes catch up to him
resulted in him going to prison to hang
out with his buddy kris who had just
been sent there at the end of season
four of cobra kai funny thing is though
greasy creasy has the last laugh by
escaping prison in a frank
sinatra-backed hannibal lecter-esque
fashion crease had orchestrated a master
plan throughout this whole season to
make his own escape faking a fight in
the prison lunchroom to make it look
like he was stabbed and died right there
only for the medical staff to realize
that the blood was actually melted red
jello the old melted jello gag that
never gets old folks then knocking out a
few guards stealing the doctor's uniform
and finally escaping through the
magnetically locked doors with that he
used his therapist badge that he had
stolen earlier on in the season crease
makes a daring escape like a fart in the
wind and leaves us on maybe one of the
biggest cliffhangers of this series yet
so with the sai kai teikai world
tournament being on the horizon and
greasy creasy slipping through the long
dong of the law i think both of these
things will be explored heavily and i
mean heavily in a potential season six
of cobra kai my thoughts are that kris
will have escaped from the united states
leaving the current state of kopakai in
shambles but trying to revive it in
either tahiti which is where he visits
in the karate kid part 3 but more than
likely he's going to be setting up shop
in south korea there was a bit of a
flashback in this season showing that he
and terry had actually trained there in
1980 with chris mentioning that he had
fond memories of potentially having a
grand champion on his hands referring to
a young johnny lawrence here's where
kris will start to build cobra kai on
almost this world scale level because at
the end of season 4 he exclaims that he
is cobra kai
meaning all of the dojo silver had built
up mean nothing without him crease will
slither his way back into facing
miyagidou head-to-head in the world sai
kai taekai tournament making his
triumphant return while once again being
a thorn in the side of both johnny and
daniel now two other dojos may pop up
and join kobrakai and miyagido in the
sai kai teikai tournament and that would
be both an unnamed dojos from chosen and
mike barnes first of which chosen even
though he got a katana to the back he
has like this reinvigorated spirit about
him and will return to okinawa island to
confess his true feelings to kumiko the
next time we see him the two of them
will either be married or an item
they're going to be together in some
fashion with him starting his own dojo
and i'm telling you it better be called
chosen one's dojo it's right there don't
mess it up it's a good thing just just
lean into it on the other hand is mike
barnes and like i mentioned earlier he
was the opponent that was hired by terry
silver in the karate kid part 3 and
essentially fell out of karate after
that movie in season five he had a
well-established life far away from
karate until it was all ruined by
terrible terry when he burned down
barnes's furniture story reeling him
back in now barnes starting his own dojo
may be a long shot but there's a few
different reasons why i think that he
might be kind of reeled back into the
action and be a bigger part in the
coming seasons first of which he wants
revenge on silver and cobra kai even if
silver is in prison colebrook high is
still out there and alive maybe not
doing well they may need to rebrand a
bit but they are still out there so a
rival dojo could help them fully put an
end to cobra kai he did say the
furniture was the only thing that he had
so he has nothing to lose and one skill
that he possesses is the art of karate
but how is he gonna fund this venture is
he gonna go around and pick up some cans
hmm
well one simple answer is the painting
that he stole
from silver's house at the end of this
season so this painting is actually
mentioned to be a rembrandt and it's
called the storm of the sea of galilee
which in real life was stolen in 1990
but was never actually recovered this
makes sense why terry would be in
possession of this painting because of
all of his sketchy business dealings and
thus is worth a ton of money that barnes
could somehow pawn off you know get a
little bit of starting cash and start
his own dojo because again i don't think
that that's the last we'll see of him
unless season six does some kind of
miyagi magic and hillary swinks julie
pierce somehow comes out of nowhere and
roundhouse kicks the fans right in the
face overall i think this fifth season
had some perfect rhythm to it but also
missing a hit here or there digging into
and playing with the previous lore was
probably the strongest attribute in my
opinion like expanding upon terry's
addiction to cobra kai's greatness
sending out cobra cutouts that instantly
reminded me of the biceps from always
sunny in philly you should have seen how
passionate you got when i showed him the
dick flyer you knew and furthering the
character development between daniel and
chosen chosen was the perfect addition
to this season bringing a new sense of
energy and fighting style while also
being the almost wild card comedic
relief character when he was needed most
and johnny now mending that father-son
bond with robbie and essentially
starting a family with carmen shows how
much his character has changed from
season one i mean he was kinda sober in
this season sure he partied a little bit
here or there but compared to the
previous seasons this dude looked like
he took a completed 12 steps of aaa
meetings here was some of this season a
bit bloated and more of a cracked boar
than fully shattering it absolutely like
miguel's father amounting to a little
less than two episodes of the story was
a huge bummer for myself with that being
such a big cliffhanger for the last
season it seemed fairly insignificant to
the grand scheme of things going around
and the complete [ __ ] of this new
sai kai taekai world championship seemed
like more of a stepping stone set up of
what is later to come in a future season
don't get me wrong the fight
choreography has improved tenfold as
these seasons have kind of continued on
but this season felt way more of the
internal drama and politics of karate in
the valley rather than people actually
getting into fisticuffs with one another
surprisingly everyone did have their
time to shine each having some sort of
internal conflict about how they should
act versus how they want to act which
makes these dojo allegiances so
interesting at the end of the day and i
love that netflix is really invested in
this series i mean a young johnny
lawrence i mean look at him look at this
guy right here you don't know which
one's which right here you ask one for
ice cream they both say yes but also the
expanding of the lore from the older
films sure they are cheesy 80s karate
flicks don't get me wrong but this
season not only pulled from some of the
great homages like tori having to break
the stone figure which is the same as
daniel having to break the wooden one in
part three or bringing back jessica
andrews and her mac and cheese recipe
great tie-in by the way but also really
building upon scary terry as a
fleshed-out character in part three he's
pretty much just a coked up dude with a
pony but they really made him even more
menacing than crease but crease also got
some really great scenes like the
therapy flashbacks and the demons that
he's dealing with kobrakai is doing
exactly what the fans of the show
already are wanting it's not like
they're reinventing the whole wax on wax
off method it's karate drama dojos
rivalry and kicks to the pants was this
season a perfectly executed tornado kick
to the face no like let me see more of
these kind of weird senseis like this
dude right here what happened to his eye
let me know but hey it was a fun cheesy
[ __ ] slap to the face i'm gonna give
this season 8 out of 10 broken boards
hey if you don't like that rating well
then don't cry over some cracked eggs
okay if anything this season massively
sets up what could be some of the best
karate yet in the sai kai takai
tournament that best be a majority of
season six hell if that goes well make
them go fight in mortal kombat i don't
give a i think it could work right you
know do some high flying bicycle kicks
the kano dude from the beach he's
already there bring him in it's all
there anyway i'd love to hear your
thoughts on whether or not this season
of cobra kai still has that bite that
has kept you around for this long we are
currently running a competition giving
away three copies yes three copies of
top gun maverick on the 15th of
september and all you have to do to have
a chance of winning this is like this
video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories on
this season of cobra [ __ ] we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that is
you folks message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch be sure to check out some of
our other cool videos right over there
like our house of dragon breakdowns or
rick and morty season six click one you
know you want to with that out of the
way thanks for sticking through this
video i've been jared and i'm gonna
continue practicing karate in my garage
i'll see you next time take care and
peace